all right Fargo are you gonna give us
one hell of a blooper reel yeah are you
gonna fuck up your lines what you had
your you gonna mess up bigger than
everyone else is ever best of them yes
you are yes you are you're gonna fuck up
so bad there's gonna be hilarious yeah
legalizing these hazardous narcotics
would be criminally irresponsible and
leave a gateway to right thing drives
legalizing these hazardous narcotics
would be criminally irresponsible and a
gateway to rising crime waves this was
this was criminal and then this was
waves and I think I think that that's
stupid yeah I'm gonna get rid of that
legalizing these hazardous narcotics
would be over criminally eros ah fuck
I'm sorry I get high on life I'm sorry I
get high on life I'm sorry I get high on
life that's totally fucked I'm sorry I
life yeah you know what I'm high right
now on life I'm sorry I get high on life
well you in fact I'm high right now on
life don't say okay fine oh yes just do
the whole thing in one go just do it how
dare you call me no how dare you call me
a narc how dare you come in not how dare
you call me a narc how dare you call me
a narc how dare you call me a narc how
dare you call me a narc how dare you
call me a narc how dare you be crazy
just like exploded like you
motherfuckers BAM
I'm Bala go see oh yeah well I've done a
little research in your late-night
shenanigans
oh yeah well I've done a little research
in your lateness
I just stir it up blunder this takuna
negligence oh yeah well I've just got oh
yeah that sucked as an actor what a
proverbial old lorry do you deny any of
the other charges disorderly conduct
serving alley illegal but a proverbial
loaded lorry do you to deny any of the
other charges disorderly conduct
disorderly conduct
serving illegal substance to a minor huh
all right numerous health code
violations numerous numerous numerous I
damned the testicle whip improperly
setting off from a cake delivery system
what the fuck Beagle improperly setting
off of a cure yeah improperly set off
from a cake delivery system the cake
delivery system Jesus I think I'm having
a stroke I can't move the left side of
my body beautiful paper
fuck me
no fuck you wow I can whistle with my
mouth open inside ah crap I can't do it
right now
it's whatever it's recorded no Laurie
this is how they work they're luring you
in with the promise of cake no Laurie
with the promise of cake no Laurie this
is how they work they're luring you with
the promise of cake no sorry
this is how they work they're luring you
at the premises no Laurie this is how
they work they're luring you in with the
promise of cake okay no Laurie this is
how they work they're luring you in with
the promise of cake no Laurie no Laurie
no Laurie this is how they work they're
luring you in with the promise of cake
of cake statement
kenka statement uh cake question no
statement is gooder they're luring you
in with the promise
hey promise of cake the power is yours
like I'm almost grabbing him yes that's
perfect
wrangling him in wrangle whatever just
do it do this slow Z because I know zoom
it's gonna be like no lorry don't listen
to them they're luring you in with the
promise of cake
no nori they're luring you with the
promise of cake no Lauri this is how
they work they're luring you in with the
promise of cake this is gonna be one of
those one cake wonders